actor K weathers best known for his role
in major blogbuster films like Rocky and
Predator has died at the age of
76 according to a statement from
weather's family obtained by deadline
the performer died in his sleep on
February first the statement read we are
deeply saddened to announce the passing
of Cole weathers Cole was an exceptional
human being who lived an extraordinary
life through his contributions to film
televis Vision the Arts and sports he
has left an indelible Mark and this
recognized worldwide and across
Generations he was a beloved brother
father grandfather partner and friend
weather that in Korea dates back to the
early 1970s spanning roughly five
decades worth of performances across
films TV and other mediums notably he is
the latest Rocky actor to pass away from
the Beloved franchise his death death
comes just several months after that of
his co-star Bert young who died in
October 2023 at the age of 83 wether
started acting in the 1970s with
appearances and action-packed television
series like the $6 Million Man and Kung
Fu however his big breakout role came
with the release of
1976's Rocky where he starred as the
film's antagonist Apollo Creed the actor
would go on to a priz the role
throughout various films in the
franchise later he appeared in various
popular and hard-hitting properties
including his turn as War veteran Al
Dylan in 1987's iconic sci-fi horror
film Predator weathers was active in the
film and TV industry up until
2023 recently he landed a recurring role
on the shortlived Chicago justice as
attorney Mark jeff which also led him to
star in several guest appearances
throughout the one Chicago procedural
franchise he also made his debut in the
Star Wars Universe in 2019 by way of the
Mandalorian in which he portrayed Bounty
Hunter associate grief ker for three
seasons a portion of weather's career
saw him behind and away from the camera
as well throughout his time in the
industry he directed many popular TV
shows including Hawaii 5 Laur in order
Chicago Med and the Mandalorian he also
worked as a voice Act during animated
series like Regular Show and video games
like Mortal Kombat X for some fans he's
well known for his scene stealing role
in arrest of development playing a
fictionalized version of himself whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa there's still plenty
of meat on that bone you take this home
throw it in a pot add some broth or
potato baby you got a stew going for
much of his life weathers engaged in a
healthy lifestyle in his youth he played
college football and joined the NFL's
Oakland Raiders for a single season in
1970 according to the actor his athletic
life proved to be a personal catharsis
separate from his acting aspirations
wethers told the Detroit news when I
found football it was a completely
different Outlet it was more about the
physicality although one does feed the
other you needed some smarts because
there were playbooks to study and film
to study to learn about the opposition
on any given week weathers was
eventually able to combine elements from
both parts of his lifestyle with his
role as Apollo Creed in the Rocky
franchise and he continued his football
career alongside his work as an actor
however the star sustained a significant
injury during the filming of 1996's Adam
Sandler LED comedy Happy Gilmore a
botched full stun for the movie
permanently damaged the actor's body
with him sustaining two fractured
vertebrae to make matters worse the
injury didn't heal correctly resulting
in a lasting physical ailment for the
remainder of his career in an interview
with GQ wethers called the injury
debilitating he recalled there were
three or four years there where I was
just in excruciating pain while the
injury healed over time wethers noted
that a small bit of pain lingered in the
decades Beyond nonetheless he continued
to actively work as an actor in
demanding projects like the Mandalorian
ending his career still at the helm of
one of Pop cultures most popular
galaxies a hugely impressive feat for
any
[Music]
actor